the international criminal court issues
an arrest warrant for Russia's president
over allegations of war crimes the
Kremlin says it's null and void what
might it all mean for Russia and for the
war in Ukraine this is Inside Story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the show I'm Sami
zaydan President Vladimir Putin has been
indicted by the international criminal
court arrest warrants have been issued
for him and Russia's children's
commissioner Maria lavova belova while
they're accused of the war crime of
illegally deporting children from
Ukraine to Russia Ukraine says sixteen
thousand children have been removed from
the country Moscow says it's brought
children to Safety in Russia from more
ravaged areas or places under attack
from Ukrainian forces Russia doesn't
recognize the court the Kremlin says the
warrants have no Force
the ICC is a puppet in the hands of the
collective West which is always willing
to carry out pseudo-jurisdiction based
on their orders
well the ICC was set up 21 years ago and
is based in The Hague the court has
tried and convicted people of war crimes
notably in Africa the former Yugoslavia
its jurisdiction is recognized by 123
countries but not by Russia China the US
and Israel among others a short time ago
I spoke to the icc's president and asked
him if he thought the warrants might
ever be executed
so as you may know the international
criminal court
has not their own enforcement mechanism
and in respect to to the enforcement of
the decision and judgments of the Court
needs to rely on the cooperation of
states
so it's obviously disabled arrest
warrants
or so after the the Aristotle to be
issued uh the
communication to all this 123 States
parties
um and the states have the legal
obligation to cooperate fully with the
court
um according to the wrong status which
may never happen according to analysts
they say there's a good chance that
these restaurants will never be executed
what impact will it have if it is never
executed what would be the point in your
opinion do you think
I think it is a point already you know
issuing a little restaurants is the
clear signal for the worlds that the
action has consequences that there is a
legal mechanism of accountability
and the international criminal court as
an independent
and impartial institution is doing its
um its job
obviously
because of State parties supplication to
and execute their restaurants of the ICC
then the the the the world is a kind of
sanction because the person and the
arrest warrant cannot simply travel to
all these countries and this is
two-thirds of the countries of the world
do you expect more arrest warrants more
indictments indictments to be issued
against Russian officials as
investigations and allegations continue
into a number of other uh incidents
in my opinion it is just a beginning of
the of the uh of the case but everything
is in the hands of the office of the
prosecutor I understand but in your
opinion do you think we'll see more
indictments of the Russian president as
well
uh it is also possible that the also the
the the case the cases we already have
these two cases will expand legally the
prosecutor is in the position to expand
also for other allegations
um and as I said it's not the the end of
the game it's just the beginning
how do you respond to allegations that
the decision by the ICC is politicized
the decision specifically to go after
Vladimir Putin
no it would be probably difficult to
convince you that it is not obviously as
I said we are an independent judicial
institution and if the prosecutor
present the evidence present the
material supporting his request to
arrest certain persons then judges
simply impartially consider whether
there is a ground to believe that this
person
um are perpetrators of the Christ under
the statute and I don't see here the the
space for the for the politicization it
is simply the judicial decision all
right this is the point by critics of
the decision they say human rights
groups well they've documented
violations by the Ukrainian side even
the members of the un independent
International Commission of inquiry on
Ukraine have said as much on the 23rd of
September 2022 why haven't we seen the
question is it indictments and arrest
warrants for the Ukrainian side
you know we are working on the base of
the principle of complementarity means
that the priority is obviously the
national jurisdiction the international
criminal court steps in only of the
national investigation prosecutor
persecution is not a possible
uh in in a case it's actually Ukrainian
one this the cooperation between the ICC
and the office of the prosecutor with
the Ukrainian authorities and they
together make a decision what can and
should be prosecuted by the national
authorities before the international
courts and what must be charged before
the international criminal court
thank you
all right let's bring in our guests now
we have joining us from Moscow Sergey
markovi former public spokesman for
President Vladimir Putin from the Hague
Toby Cadman international human rights
lawyer and international criminal court
specialist and from London Dennis
krivoshiev Deputy Regional director at
amnesty International's Eastern Europe
and Central Asia regional office good to
have you with us if I could start with
Toby let's start with some basic facts
of what we know who was taken deported
from Ukraine how many there's been a lot
of different numbers and and claims
circulating
thank you so
um first of all as as we know the
existence of the arrest warrant um has
been made public
um but the underlying details as to the
numbers
um as to the the identity of of the
children
um have not been made public
um and is unlikely to be made public for
some time
um obviously there have been varying
different accounts of of tens hundreds
thousands obviously we don't know what
is the the evidence that the prosecutor
has relied on but certainly the the
pre-trial chamber the authorized the
issuance of the arrest warrant
um and the publication of the existence
of the rest warrant and are satisfied
that there is a strong evidential basis
um for that for that warrant so we have
to assume
um based on the principle that the ICC
works on on those most serious cases and
test of gravity the the numbers are High
um again we can't speculate
um but we all know in the fullness of
time
um given When Vladimir Putin is arrested
and faces trial all right let me take
that point to Sergey in Moscow so we
should assume uh Toby said there that
there's strong evidentiary basis for the
suggestion the allegation that Russia
engaged in what is not allowed according
to international law why would Russia
engage in such an activity to remove
particularly children illegally in
violation of the laws of war
base is just falsification and fake news
which is uh created by tools
by these organization which under the
not lost its independency and now under
the control of the political Elite of
the Western countries which conducted
hybrid war against Russia and Ukraine
and who support clear repressive uh
regime in Ukraine and in Russia it's not
so much angry
about this decision of international
criminal court but more irony they look
like clouds Frankly Speaking because
Russia as you may know moved a lot of
people from the uh from their life Zone
from those Zone which is under the
artillery of the
Ukrainian Army which is a country on the
control of the key repressive regime and
more a few a few hundreds of children in
dunbas have been killed by Ukrainian
artillery that's why Russia moved and
saved these children when they moved
there to the secure Zone and put there
to the special children's
senatorials with very good health
condition as their parents absolutely
happy to do that and there are lines
among the parents who ask local
officials to send their children to Azul
senatorials to the uh to the safe Zone
Toby was was shaking his head I take it
not in a lot of agreement I'll give you
a chance to come back in Toby for a
quick comment on that before we go to
Dennis
yeah well unfortunately it's the it's
it's the kind of uh rhetoric it's it's
the same narrative it's the same
response that we've heard uh many times
um it becomes very personalized
um um just based on insults
um it's not it's it's not a mature
engagement with the process of course
but Toby if I if I could jump in if if a
power says we want to move kids away
from harm from what what according to
the Russian narrative is Ukrainian
shelling that is endangering children in
the east of the country that isn't a
serious and mature
um allegation or or point no the
response I'm talking about about the
response referring to uh as clowns uh um
as an illegitimate process there needs
to be proper engagement of course
um the the defense that that
um or any other Russian defendant will
put on will be that of course they were
moving those children to protect them
from shelling protect them from greater
harm that's a defense that they they
will put forward and of course the
prosecution satisfied that they have
enough evidence to show that that is not
right that is not what happened right
right all right I want to bring Dennis
in you of course look at things from the
perspective Amnesty International on the
ground what do we know what the human
rights groups know about those who are
moved to Russia given what Sergey said
about some of them were happy to be
removed they wanted to get out of the
line of fire how you know how does what
you document stack up with that how much
of them or how many of them were ethnic
Russians although ukrainians are ethnic
Russians who may genuinely not wanted
their kids to continue to live in a
danger zone
sure well let me first go to your first
question there's quite a lot of detail I
mean it's not much but enough detail no
one in answer to
what are we dealing with
um if you look at the statement which
international criminal court prosecuted
Mr Khan ish released yesterday he speaks
that his team was reliant on deportation
of at least hundreds of Russian children
oh sorry Ukrainian children uh to Russia
and he's speaking specifically of
children who were in orphanages and
children's institutions in Ukraine so
we're dealing with the fact there is a
considerable number of children who were
in these institutions in Ukraine before
Russian occupation some territories were
liberated this is the institutions that
his Mr Khan's team was able to visit
those children are not there that's a
fact they were removed What's
significant here the very not from
Harm's Way they were removed permanently
and some of Russia's policies including
things that Mr Putin uh signed as
president
points to a policy of their permanent
removal including making facilitating
the process of quick
transfer of these children to Russian
citizenship and then enabling their
adoption quick adoption by Russian
families now on the fact again this I'd
like to stress two things there's a
we're no precious little detail on a lot
of these children is missing figures may
be disputed but the actual fact of
forcible removal of Ukrainian children
by Russian forces into Russia is an
established fact and based on this
someone has to face a Justice and now we
know who it who it will be for our part
you asked what honesty does on others we
are trying to follow what's happening on
the ground we're documenting quite a lot
of such instances Amnesty International
published a report where it is
documented forcible removal there
interpretation and possible transfer of
lots of Ukrainian civilians into Russia
or deeper into territories occupied
controlled by Russia and when we're
dealing with this and that massive scale
we're talking of War crime and possibly
of crime against humanity and can I also
respond to one point made by Mr Marcus
briefly the Russian his response and
Russian authorities response points to
voluntary transfer of lots of Ukrainian
civilians interaction that's true but we
cannot conflict two facts there's one
thing when there are families who move
to Russia and do so out of their own
will there's another one they do so
against their will or don't have the
choice to go into Ukraine and third is
unaccompanied children and it's the
unaccompanied children from institutions
which were there and aren't now all
right that's a good point I want to give
Sergey a chance to come back in on that
particularly then Sergey the the
allegation amounts to the removal of
unaccompanied children particularly some
of them may have been from orphanages
where there is no parental consent and
they remove the allegation goes to be
settled not temporarily but permanently
perhaps naturalized settled into Russian
families that exceeds the sort of
standard procedure of Simply moving
civilians out of Harm's Way right Sergey
uh philosopher it's a artificially
created a pattern model first of all
between the Russians and ukrainians
there are no big
difference it's uh not uh as between uh
three ancient British it's something
like between uh British and uh
Scottish but that might be in the
Russian but obviously ukrainians might
have a difference yeah it's not but it's
not Russia perspective it perspective of
all Oracle documents during one thousand
year uh ukrainians each part of the big
Russian people that's why by the way uh
our people saw that calls them
acquaintance they're ukrainians but
sometimes they're Russians that's right
and those people who I live in those
regions which join now uh Russia as they
speak Russian language I am 90 percent
according to any
um evaluations and if these people uh
you have no parents uh we must give new
parents to those people but same time
Russian government if you know respects
very much it's one of the reasons of
criticism from the Western countries
against Vladimir Putin exactly for
protection of biological government
these family values and some kind of
opposition to the ideology of lgbtq
verification and uh Russian government
respect Family Values very much that's
why if during the war some of the
children are lost their parents then the
experience appeal to be on the territory
which is controlled by Keith regime
there are a lot of cases when Russian
governments move those children uh to
the uh territory which is controlled by
Keith regime because their parents there
is absolutely normal for us as for
normal people right and uh
let me bring in Toby and ask this
question at the end of the day
will this warrant practically speaking
ever be executed
um it's entirely possible that it could
be executed
um obviously
um whether Russia
um acknowledges the existence of uh the
jurisdiction of the ICC is is completely
irrelevant it still does have
jurisdiction over crimes that have have
occurred in
um in Ukraine
um no Russia is unlikely to hand over
its president it's a nuclear-armed
country this isn't the former Yugoslavia
right so you know yeah certainly and so
so it's it's unlikely that that uh Putin
will voluntarily surrender to the ICC
um despite uh what the statements coming
out that that obviously has a very
strong defense to this as as the Mr
Markov has already stated but the fact
of the matter is if he travels outside
of his borders if he travels to a state
that is also a member of the ICC there
is a risk that he could be handed over
and the next trip that he has planned is
in August to go to South Africa for the
Brit Summit now it may well be and South
Africa has recently uh withdrawn its own
withdrawal from the ICC so the the
situation that happened with South
Africa previously with al-Bashir from
Sudan and failing to hand him over to
the ICC I don't think that they would
make the same mistake twice
um so whilst it may be considered
theoretical
um there is a risk of Vladimir Putin
being arrested in another state and
handed over to the ICC where head of
state immunity does not exist so so yes
there is there is a great possibility
um it may take time it's not going to
happen immediately but it will certainly
impact on his ability to to to remain
head of state all right let me put a
question back to Dennis now human rights
groups including Amnesty International
including the un independent
International Commission of inquiry for
you train have documented what they call
human rights violations by Ukrainian
forces
the question that we often hear from the
Russian perspective and narrative or
supporters of it is why aren't we seeing
any indictments why aren't we seeing any
arrest warrants for the other side
well I think the quick answer to that
history doesn't live here in fact
history is being made by yesterday's
decision so we may very well see
indictments facing the other side but
for now
giving what's happening on the ground
and the evidence we're receiving this is
perhaps one of the biggest most evidence
most appalling abuses which amounts to
war crime and and we
salute the icc's decision to proceed
with this world by the way in the
statement which in the in the press
release which the international premium
quote released end in a statement by Mr
Khan Point distressed and I will stress
it too this is not the only War crime
for which
indictments needs to follow with every
day the list of war crimes and other
crimes on the international law which
are being documented which are being
tragically committed by Russian forces
and Ukraine is growing and for all of
those time will come for someone to be
indicted but then answer to your
question if the other side commits war
crimes similarly same process should
apply and to answer the question on uh
what follows uh I think there's one key
Point here by releasing the information
on the arrest warrant now there ICC is
sending a signal
actions of this nature will have
consequences uh the in unlawful transfer
of an involuntary transfer deportation
of Ukrainian civilians continues that
message should put or at least uh serve
as a break for those who are doing it
because uh the back doesn't stop with Mr
Putin others will have to face and
perhaps these criminal orders will be
less well executed or stopped now that
that should be the first point and then
getting him to face the court and Mis uh
Dennis do you really think that will
that will happen and that principle of
justice of accountability will be
applied to all of those accused of war
crimes irrespective of how powerful they
are in the world and any politics
well that's certainly the principle on
which we as a human rights movement in
states that we will work towards it okay
let me bring in Sergey once again and
shift the question to a point which you
touched on earlier sir what impact is
this going to have on the war on
diplomacy will it make negotiations
harder right now
from European unions that uh it will be
no negotiation but on the war and War
and blood and uh until uh last uh
Ukrainian uh will die
um it's uh we understand the signal uh
same time it will have not a real uh
influence on the diplomacy of Russia but
it will be influenced this international
criminal court Frankly Speaking
colleagues they recognize there's a
clown style stupid absolutely
irresponsible uh fake decision of this
uh Court uh go ahead Dennis but very
briefly then is keep it very briefly
well I mean there's a lot to respond to
the disrespectful nature of comments
from Mr Markov doesn't encourage me but
I'd like to say this nonetheless uh
Russia claims that 150 children died in
in Danielle's conservatives around it
which Russia controlled since 2014 now
leaving apart the reason why they died
and why the conflict started in Russia's
role in it hundreds more children died
as a result of Russia's war of
aggression against Ukraine right so if
it started this to save children well it
cost hundreds and hundred years
you've made that point I want to give
Toby a quick Final on a final Point
briefly what happens in the process
what's the possibility that an arrest
warrant can be rescinded if there is
some kind of political
resolution
um it can
um and I appreciate that's the question
that you asked but there's so much to
answer to to what Mr Markov has just
said
um and I'm sorry if I um don't deal with
that of course the the rest one could be
could be withdrawn it's unlikely but if
we if we just break apart what Mr
Markovich has said
um that the wall will carry on until
um every Ukrainian will die well that's
reminiscent of of a genocidal language
and I think he needs to be very very
careful what what kind of remarks he
makes
um particularly on a public broadcast
um again it was Russia that invaded
um Ukraine to say that Russia is abiding
by all International treaties and
Ukraine is not is is just goes against
everything that we know this is a
process that will continue whether we
see Vladimir Putin in the Hebrew not
anytime soon
um I I can't say but this process will
continue there has to be a process of
justice and accountability and those who
have committed such heinous crimes must
and will be be held accountable for
their actions this is it's an aggression
against Ukraine and it's quite right
that the arrest warrant has been issued
and I applaud the prosecutor for doing
it for having The Bravery to do it let's
leave it there there's I know there's a
lot more that we can go on discussing
but let us thank very much our guests
Toby Sergey and Dennis
and thank you two for watching you can
see the show again anytime by visiting
our website Al jazeera.com and for
further discussion head over to our
Facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash AJ Inside Story let's also
join the conversation on Twitter I'll
handle there is at AJ inside story from
me Sami zaidan and the whole team here
for now it's goodbye
thank you